all right I read through the rough
transcript of the call between Trump and
the new Ukrainian president and a few
things struck me number one there's not
a single person in Washington with any
experience in government not one who
really believes the president was trying
to use the Ukrainian government to rig
the 2020 election I don't see how anyone
in his or her right mind could
legitimately say there's an impeachable
offense in this transcript in the
conversation Trump congratulated
Vladimir Solinsky on his parliamentary
win and said the US would continue to
support Ukraine but he was frustrated
that the EU isn't doing more zalenski
agreed saying the European Union should
be our biggest partner but technically
the United States is a much bigger
partner we're ready to continue to
cooperate for the next step specifically
we're almost ready to buy more javelins
from the United States for defense
purposes then the president responds I
would like you to do us a favor though
because our country has been through a
lot and Ukraine knows a lot about it I
would like you to find out what happened
with this whole situation with Ukraine
they say CrowdStrike the server they say
Ukraine has it I would like to have the
Attorney General call you or your people
and I would like you to get to the
bottom of it whatever you can do it's
very important that you do it if that's
possible
zalinsky then interjected that one of
his assistants had already met with
Giuliani and that the investigation was
very important for him as well adding I
guarantee that all the investigations
will be done openly and then candidly
that I can assure you
okay handling investigations openly and
candidly that sounds like an evil plot
to me how nefarious of them there is no
quid pro quo and the president never
once even hinted that Ukrainian aid
would be withheld if a further
investigation by them wasn't done at
this point I think it's pretty obvious
that the Democrats overplayed their hand
big time they base their impeachment
move on a whistleblower who didn't even
hear the conversation and
grossly exaggerated what happened in it
which brings me to point number two the
president not only did nothing wrong he
went above and beyond his duty to his
office hoping to discover what happened
in the lead-up to the 2016 election so
it never happens to another president
again as we know the Biden story is
about far more than just hunter Biden
making big money in Ukraine while daddy
was setting ukraine policy i fully
support transparency when these
so-called whistleblower information but
also insist on transparency from Joe
Biden and his son hunter on the millions
of dollars that have been quickly and
easily taken out of Ukraine and China if
foreign governments were approached to
assist in digging up dirt on Trump the
lead up to 2016 that is a big problem
and Trump's right we need to get to the
bottom of any election tampering the
Democrats wanted to stop election
meddling by foreign governments which
takes us to point number three Democrats
don't really care about preventing
government corruption any Democrat
claiming to be interested in corruption
should be outraged by the fact that
Biden himself bragged on camera about
dangling a foreign aid carrot to get a
prosecutor fired when that prosecutor
was involved in investigating a company
paying his son boatloads of cash not a
single that not a single Democrat will
even concede that Biden's actions at the
very least were an obvious conflict of
interest is extremely telling guys I
believe in six hours if the prosecutors
not fired you're not getting the money
Oh son got fired number four if
President Trump wanted to pressure
Ukraine to hurt Biden with the intent on
improving his own reelection chances
there were a hundred better ways to do
it
by the way ways that wouldn't involve
speaking to the Ukrainian president on
the phone when he knows that the call is
monitored and memorial
it's by intelligent staffers and while
the Democrats insist Trump was
pressuring Ukraine to investigate Biden
what is the ukrainian President himself
say about it we had I think good phone
call it was normal we spoke about many
things and I so I think and you read it
that nobody pushed it pushed me yes
nobody pushed him so the principal
himself adamant no pressure from Trump
the call was normal nothing out of the
ordinary so are the impeachment dem
saying that Zielinski here on camera is
lying so it's a trump Ukrainian
conspiracy in plain sight now does all
this kind of sound familiar to any of
you phony collusion claims in 2017 phony
pressure claims now number 5 there are
no moderates left in the Democrat Party
this point is beyond debate during the
midterm swing district Democrats claimed
they were anxious to work with the
president now they are the tips of the
impeachment sphere the quid pro quo
element doesn't need to be there for
this to be a crime this was a line that
was crossed for the national security
Dems and something that we thought the
caucus needed to move on while it may be
a controversial issue and when you look
at the facts and you look at this
specific instance I think this is a
total game changer as a game changer for
the Democrat Party they're all ilana
Omar now when there are for re-election
next year and they insist oh they insist
their moderates who just want government
to work again don't believe them they
must be voted out of office for
violating their pledge to be more
bipartisan number six Democrat
leadership has totally given up on
governing now time and again Trump is
beating them at their own game we've
seen it and I'm beginning to think it's
made them
I think there's losing it day after day
they're totally delusional
you know the lunatic hobos who blurt out
crazy
things and they zigzag in the middle of
a crowded intersection
well Adam Schiff kind of sounded like
that today
what those notes reflect is a classic
mafia like shakedown of a foreign leader
this is how a mafia boss talks like any
mafia boss the president didn't need to
say that's a nice country you have it'd
be a shame if something happened to it
the man doesn't even know the Godfather
okay he doesn't even know the movie he
doesn't even know what a shakedown is I
still remember by the way when the
Democrats did tell us that they were
going to work on health care and
infrastructure they were going to take
on the drug companies they're not going
to do any of that which takes us to my
seventh and final points biblical here
all right Democrats are possessed with
anti-trump rage maybe there needs to be
an exorcism
they are infuriated that Muller let them
down that Trump has beaten them pretty
much at every turn they're obsessed with
punishing him and anyone who works for
him anyone who's close to him think
about it does leadership give
impassioned press conferences on their
plans for reining in government waste
and fraud and abuse or improving the
economy no they save all their emotion
and bogus investigations and angry
denunciations of anyone associated with
this president the polls are clear this
is not what Americans want these
representatives were not sent to
Washington to frustrate the people's
will they were sent to Washington to do
the people's will and at this point
Trump's doing that all on his own soon
though it's going to turn to the people
they'll have their say they're gonna let
Washington know what it thinks about the
job they've done and properly framed the
election will be a choice between the
Democrats revenge and resist style
politics or the president's results and
unfortunately for a Pelosi and Schiff
you can't impeach your own constituents
and that's the angle